I love you.
Hey.
How many were there before me?
What do you mean?
Like how many girls did you love before me?
Love?
Five.
I loved five women before you.
What are their names?
Who, what, when, where, why.
Can you tell me about them?
Who I loved was a girl from college.
I wasn't exactly close to her but...
...with some superficial facts and a few interactions over semester...
...like most guys fantasizing over a girl they barely know.
I filled in the blanks like a fairy tale author.
And who she became in my head was probably more than the reality.
She was a third year, sorority girl.
Yeah!
And I was the infatuated freshman, sure, but the several times we got to spend together outside of class...
...It really allowed me to see, she also had a good heart and a bright spirit.
The only problem was, so did just about every other guy.
And while she turned me down nicely,...
...I swear, there were times when it seemed like the cliche sorority girl...
...may have felt something for the typical awkward freshman.